We are once again faced with the combination
of ignorance and arrogance from Donald Trump
and it's always a perfect storm of what I
call weaponized ignorance around the economy.
Specifically, remember when Donald Trump called
now criminal national security advisor, Michael
Flynn in the middle of the night to ask him,
hey, is a strong dollar or a weak dollar better
for the American economy?
Donald Trump dealing with the economy is sort
of like you realize your car needs, the transmission
rebuilt and you bring it to a guy who only
knows how to diagnose whether the car is out
of gas or not, and often even diagnosis that
incorrectly.
You're not even going to be able to assess
the transmission with the guy who can only
read the gas, uh, gas reading.
Uh, and that is similar to what is going on
with Donald Trump and the American economy.
Maybe a better analogy is your engine blows
and you bring the car to a bakery.
The Baker is equivalent to Donald Trump dealing
with the economy.
It was a signal when Trump called Michael
Flynn and said, is a strong dollar or a weak
dollar good that this is not a guy who knows
anything about the economy and Donald Trump
tweeting yesterday, quote Jay Powell and the
Federal Reserve fail again, no guts, no sense,
no vision, a terrible communicator.
So to really do this correctly, we've got
to go through it sequentially.
Donald Trump has continued to just rage over
the idea that the economy would be doing way
better today if the Federal Reserve would
help them out with more and bigger federal
funds, rate cuts in the way that Trump believes
they've quote helped out previous presidents.
Now Donald Trump has gotten two rate cuts
recently.
I believe it was August 1st he got a 25 basis
point cut around August 1st.
Don't, don't, don't remember the exact date.
And then you've got another 25 basis point
cut yesterday.
25 basis points is like 0.25%.
But Trump is insisting it's just not enough.
And the truth is that both increases and decreases
to the federal funds rate.
Can quote help a president because the logic
is if you cut the federal funds rate, it makes
it cheaper for banks to borrow money and that
can conceivably stimulate economic activity
and that will boost the stock market.
And it will give something to Donald Trump
to brag about how great the economy is doing.
But when the federal funds rate is increased,
it can also help the economy in that the Fed
must see the economy as being strong enough
to tolerate a rate increase signaling that
things must be going pretty well.
So, first of all, it's not even cut and dry
that only rate cuts help a president, uh,
look better in terms of the economy that they
are stewards of.
But to analyze this outlandish behavior by
Donald Trump, you also have to dig deeper
about in the modern economy, does a rate cut
even really do the things that we historically
believed rate cuts would do?
And the answer is only sort of the, the mechanism
that is imagined for a rate cut to help the
economy is the Federal Reserve cuts the rate.
This leads to Americans buying more durable
goods like cars and stuff like that.
Interest rates drop on mortgages, so people
will buy houses, uh, they will refinance mortgages
and save money and have some extra money every
month to spend on other stuff.
But the reality is that as the economy continues
to modernize, the uh, reality is a federal
funds rate cut of 25 or 50 basis points is
not going to have that significant an effect.
People aren't saving up waiting for a rate
cut and then they go out and they get a car
and a house and refinance spending has much
more of a natural cycle that's related to
a where in life people are and and uh, other
factors.
And in addition to that, you've got to remember
that the bottom half of the economy has had
stagnant wages for like 40 years.
So at 25 basis point cut or a 50 basis point
cut or a 75 basis point cut is not going to
stimulate any significant amount of spending.
For a lot of those people, they just don't
have any money.
So the long and short of it is that even this
reliance on rate cuts to quote jumpstart an
economy or to prevent the recession, it's
old thinking.
It's of course based on the sort of economic
status quo that has not been good for half
of the country.
Anyway, that's a bigger conversation.
And of course Donald Trump is furious, not
only about only getting another 25 basis points.
He's furious that the Fed is predicting GDP
growth of only 2.2% this year.
Remember he was promising three, four, I think
he even talked about 5% GDP growth under his
presidency.
Of course, it's not happening.
It was never going to happen and sadly the
Trump stuff around this is a really big distraction
from some bigger economic questions that we
don't have answers to.
Trump is flat out wrong about the federal
funds rate.
Trump is attacking the federal, uh, the Federal
Reserve chief that he selected, Jerome Powell.
I mean, it's crazy, but it's a distraction
from what happens to the economy if we don't
deal with climate change isn't an economy
that is based on infinite growth on a planet
of limited resources.
Fundamentally a mathematical impossibility.
How good is an economy really?
Even if the stock market is high or unemployment
is low, if half the country can't afford an
unexpected $400 expense or is one illness
away from bankruptcy, there are really important
questions to solve about the economy.
Some of which we're going to talk with progressive
economists, Dean Baker later on today, which
I really look forward to.
Donald Trump doesn't even understand the problems,
nevermind potential solutions.
And that's probably the biggest tragedy of
all of this.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
And while you're there, follow me at David.
Dot.
Pacman.
I people loving, loving the picture.
I posted with my dad's dog yesterday, a Nimo,
the English lab who has gone gray.
He has a gray beard now, not me.
The dog.
Follow me on Instagram at David Dot.
Packman follow the show on Instagram at David
Pakman show.
Quick break back after this